über 300 firmen weltweit haben
usbekische baumwolle aufgrund von
zwangsarbeit gebannt darunter firmen wie
h&m und zara
trotzdem steckt in viel kleidung noch
usbekische baumwolle
die hauptstadt taschkent usbekistan gilt
als autokratie und die baumwolle ist der
größte devisenbringer für das land
der journalist timor karpov berichtet
seit langem kritisch über zwangsarbeit
bei der baumwollernte die situation soll
sich in den letzten jahren zwar
verbessert haben aber das problem
besteht weiterhin wie ist die aktuelle
situation in usbekistan
es ist sehr schwierig und gefährlich an
dem thema baumwolle zu arbeiten vor
allem für filmemacher und journalisten
passieren wirklich böse sachen mit
leuten die zu neugierig sind
wir wollen wissen wie die situation auf
den feldern ist und verlassenen
taschkent
es ist erntezeit und die felder sind
voller arbeiter
[Musik]
timor karpov hat uns genaue anweisungen
für die dreharbeiten gegeben wenn wir
aussteigen haben wir ein zeitfenster von
15 minuten um mit den menschen zu
sprechen danach kommt meist die polizei
und dann wird es schwierig
karpov wurde schon mehrere male
verhaftet und zusammengeschlagen
laut menschenrechtsorganisationen sollen
staatsbedienstete auf den feldern zur
arbeit gezwungen werden
ich bin eigentlich krankenschwester und
arbeitet zurzeit in schichten
ab 9 uhr morgens bin ich hier auf dem
feld
und um sieben uhr abends beginnt mein
dienst im krankenhaus
oft sollen menschen durchs halbe land
geschickt werden um zu ernten
staatsbedienstete haben meist keine wahl
und werden einfach abkommandiert
doch viele sind die harte arbeit auf dem
feld nicht gewohnt
durch den vielen staub sind meine lippen
aufgerissen
der staub löst viele energien aus
auf unsere frage ob sie freiwillig hier
sind oder zur arbeit gezwungen werden
erhalten wir keine antwort
[Musik]
der ernte leiter behauptet dass alle
arbeiter aus dem nachbardorf stammen und
freiwillig hier sind wir haben zweifel
es ist wirklich schwierig hier die
wahrheit zu erkennen alles klingt
verworren und kompliziert es sieht
wirklich so aus als ob diese menschen
hier zwangsarbeiter sind
man fordert uns auf zu gehen und das
filmen einzustellen
nicht weit entfernt lägen wir uns auf
die lauer wir wollen herausfinden ob die
arbeiter wirklich aus dem nachbardorf
stammen
[Musik]
wohin gehen sie nach der arbeit
ihr ziel ein verfallener hof
eine massen unterkunft für fremdarbeiter
humor nimmt kontakt auf
die 15 menschenleben in diesem raum es
ist die männer unterkunft
die bedingungen hier sind hart aber
völlig normal diese zustände findet man
im ganzen land
statt glas in den fenstern gibt es hier
plastikfolie
dann könnt ihr nach hause gehen
insgesamt sind wir einen monat hier 16
tage haben wir noch vor uns ja in 16
tagen geht es zurück ich vermisse mein
zuhause
sie stammen aus krokant einem ort 400
kilometer entfernt
16 frauen schlafen hier auf dem fußboden
nachdem sie von morgens bis abends
baumwolle gepflückt haben auch sie
wollen nicht in die kamera sagen ob sie
zur arbeit gezwungen werden oder nicht
dann wird karpov nervös
wir sind schon viel zu lange ich möchte
nicht wieder in die situation kommen
dass die polizei uns verhaftet und uns
zusammen schlägt und alles durchsucht
ich will das nicht noch einmal erleben
deshalb kommt
timor will uns zeigen was die baumwolle
ökologisch anrichtet
wir fahren immer entlang des amu darya
einst ein gewaltiger strom heute nur
noch ein rinnsal
sein wasser wird auf die baumwollfelder
geleitet eine katastrophe für den
aralsee
wo einst cheffe fuhren ist heute wüste
[Musik]
mienack einst hafenstadt heute wüstenort
wir besuchen einen der letzten fischer
der stadt den 82 jährigen thomas beumers
erst langen zur see gefahren zuletzt als
kapitän
heute sitzt er meist zu hause
[Musik]
ohne
früher war es hier wunderschön
überall
[Musik]
heute fehlt nur noch schreckliche
sandstürme durch die stadt bringen staub
und
hier gibt es nur noch sand und keinen
tropfen wasser mehr
dann zeigt er uns einen ort an dem er
schon lange nicht mehr war
den alten hafen von marina
[Musik]
den letzten weg zu seinem alten schiff
der wolga möchte er allein gehen
[Musik]
ja
als dass sie noch voll wasser war musste
man gut navigieren kann
die wellen waren hoch und unruhig
sie schlugen oft heftig auf mein boot
ein
nur wenige jahrzehnte hat der
baumwollanbau gebraucht den ganzen see
austrocknen zu lassen
wir sind wieder im baumwollanbau gebiet
unterwegs timo hat ein treffen mit einem
bauern arrangiert
hat kann speck hatte land gepachtet und
seine felder bestellt denn alles land
gehört dem staat früher hat die kolchose
alles bestimmt heute die sogenannte
cluster verwaltung und die hat ihm alles
genommen
heute ist er verarmt und lebt mit seiner
familie im haus seines bruders
sie zwingen die menschen baumwolle
anzupflanzen auch wenn sie lieber gemüse
und sowas anbauen möchten den bauern die
widersprechen wird das land einfach
weggenommen ich habe etwas gemüse
angebaut musste aber auf dem größten
teil meines landes baumwolle platz
ich fand es furchtbar
deshalb entschloss ich mich im nächsten
jahr keine baumwolle mehr zu pflanzen
daraufhin haben sie mir mein land
weggenommen sie haben ja nichts bezahlt
alles war komplett illegal
kam später auf hat auf rückgabe des
landes geklagt doch das gericht lässt
den fall ins nichts laufen obwohl die
landnahme auch nach usbekischen gesetz
illegal ist
irgendwie versucht er nun sich über
wasser zu halten
hier stehe ich nun an versuche ein paar
hühner züchten
die hoffnung sein land zurück zu
bekommen hat er aufgegeben die cluster
sind zu mächtig und auf seinen
gemüsefeldern wächst längst wieder
baumwolle
zurück in taschkent wir wollen mit dem
vorsitzenden des clusters sprechen der
den bauern sein land genommen haben soll
außerdem ist er direktor dieser
baumwollspinnerei
er hat gute kontakte zum usbekischen
präsidenten und verteidigt die landnahme
reformen sind nicht immer gut für alle
menschen nur für manche
familie hat das land länger als 30 jahre
bewirtschaftet und die produktivität der
ernte ging nach unten
was hätten wir in so einem fall tun soll
bauer hat ja auch verpflichtungen
zum beispiel muss er einen gewissen
ertrag erzielen
viele menschen unterstützen diese reform
illegale landnahme werden so einfach zu
reformen
wir fliegen zurück nach deutschland
obwohl baumwolle aus usbekistan von
vielen firmen geächtet wird sollen
deutsche zwischenhändler usbekische
gerne kaufen und verkaufen wie die firma
retex in mönchengladbach
firmeninhaber und geschäftsführer knut
ritters ist bereit uns ein interview zu
geben
sie handeln jetzt wie kommt das
sicherlich hat es einen sehr negativen
einnahmen aus der vergangenheit thema
zwangsarbeit und andere standards die
eben nicht eingehalten wurden es gibt
eben auch viele organisationen geradeaus
von europäischer seite die dem land sehr
große fortschritte auch unter dem neuen
präsidenten ja zugestehen und ja auch
nach meiner kenntnis sowohl das
wirtschaftsministerium wie auch das
auswärtige amt dafür plädieren diesen
banden aufzuheben nur ist es eine echte
ökologische katastrophe die dirham der
aralsee ist praktisch komplett
ausgetrocknet macht man sich da nicht
ein stück weit schuldig auch immer das
handelt
ich glaube auch dass da sich sehr viel
durch neue technologien verbessert hat
in den letzten jahren
ja schuld
ich denke wir können wurde das insgesamt
verbessern wenn wir darauf aufmerksam
machen dass man über neue technologien
arbeitet und dann eben auch mit
entsprechenden organisationen und
verbänden darauf die lokalen bauern
einwirkt
die baumwollproduktion ist immer noch
hoch problematisch aber bei der
weiterverarbeitung von textilien wollte
sich ex minister müller für vernünftige
sozial und umweltstandards einsetzen
deshalb hat das ministerium 2009 10 den
grünen knopf eingeführt das textil
siegel findet man bei einigen händlern
auch bei discountern wie aldi und lidl
aber hat das label etwas gebracht wir
haben eingekauft baumwollkleidung mit
dem grünen knopf dieses shirt zum
beispiel stammt von lidl über den grünen
knopf kann man die genaue herkunft zwar
nicht bestimmen aber über ein anderes
label produziert wurde es von der firma
die in bangladesch
wir machen uns auf den weg nach
bangladesch
das südasiatische land ist eines der
ärmsten länder der erde
da kam die hauptstadt bangladeschs
eine der am schnellsten wachsenden
städte der welt
um die 18 millionen menschen leben hier
viele unterhalb der armutsgrenze
die meisten von ihnen arbeiten in der
textilindustrie
die hilfsorganisation kümmert sich um
die arbeiter in den fabriken wir fragen
den vize präsidenten der organisation
nach der fabrik des lidl shirts
kennen sie diese fabrik
ja das ist eine fabrik wie alle anderen
auch keine unterschiede
was denken sie über die textil sehen
ich glaube dass all die zertifikate und
siegel nur den modemarken nutzen
sie haben einen verkaufsvorteil durch
sie ansonsten akzeptieren die einkäufer
keine preiserhöhungen sondern fragen
immer nur nach noch günstigeren preisen
sie wollen es immer noch billiger und
billiger
wie sich die einkäufer vor ort verhalten
können wir nicht überprüfen aber naja
idol will uns die realität in den
textilfabriken bangladesch zeigen egal
ob sie zertifiziert sind oder nicht wir
haben viele fabriken schriftlich um
drehgenehmigungen gebeten nicht einer
hat geantwortet
mitten in der stadt liegt der älteste
slum dakars
hier wohnen vor allem arbeiter aus der
textilindustrie mit ihren familien
[Musik]
in diesem verschlag wohnen elf familien
teilen sich drei kochstellen eine
toilette und
eine waschecke
wir besuchen eine näherin sie nennt uns
den namen der fabrik in der sie arbeitet
auch diese fabrik hat verschiedene
zertifizierungen und produziert für
bekannte modelabel sagt man uns
von unserem lohn können wir uns gerade
mal dieses zimmer leisten und meist
etwas zu essen
sparen können wir nichts davon wir
müssen dann auch noch für die
kühlschrank nutzung zahlen
die schule unserer tochter kostet auch
geld und wenn es irgendwie geht
versuchen wir noch die eltern meines
mannes zu unterstützen
obwohl sie um die 120 euro verdient das
ist mehr als der mindestlohn bleibt oft
nicht einmal genug um satt zu werden
hier siehst du was all den grünen
zertifikate und textil siegel der
modemarken und zertifizierer bringen
so leben unsere arbeiter wirklich
sie bekommen nicht einmal genug zu essen
das ist das wahre gesicht der menschen
die eure kleider
der nächste morgen wir haben die
möglichkeit eine fabrik zu besuchen die
sehr gute arbeitsbedingungen haben soll
um acht uhr strömen tausende arbeiter
zum schichtwechsel
die security der fabrik gleicht einer
kleinen armee
erster ort der besichtigungstour das
lager wir sehen baumwollstoffe aus der
ganzen welt auch aus usbekistan
wir entdecken eine tafel eine kundin h&m
tommy hilfiger s.oliver esprit zara und
viele mehr
im nächsten stockwerk die näherei hier
werden gerade jeans für die modemarke
zara produziert
wie in den meisten anderen fabriken
arbeiten die näherinnen sechs tage die
woche acht stunden am tag mit
überstunden weist um die zehn stunden
der gesetzliche mindestlohn in
bangladesch beträgt 8000 acker das sind
umgerechnet rund 80 euro im monat
damit kommt kein arbeiter über die
runden
8000 tucker das maximum 15.000 für die
arbeiter in diesem bereich die manager
verdienen natürlich mehr
selbst hier wird also nur wenig mehr
bezahlt als der mindestlohn von dem man
sich kaum das leben in einem slum
leisten kann
wir fliegen zurück nach deutschland
möchten ein interview mit lidl führen
doch eine antwort gibt es nur
schriftlich unter anderem heißt es um
unseren unternehmerischen
sorgfaltspflichten bei sozial- und
umweltstandards in der lieferkette
nachzukommen lassen wir textilien die
beispielsweise das langarmshirt der
eigenmarke liberty durch den grünen
knopf zertifizieren und das siegel auf
den produktverpackungen abbilden
was bringt aber der grüne knopf wenn die
arbeiterinnen in bangladesch trotzdem
keine besseren bedingungen haben als in
anderen fabriken wir fragen bei den
verantwortlichen für das siegel nach dem
ministerium für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung
versteht er nicht ab ich hab mir das nur
aufgeschrieben der grüne knopf ist ein
staatliches siegel für sozial und
ökologisch nachhaltig produzierte
textilien die von verantwortungsvoll
handelnden unternehmen in den verkehr
gebracht werden ich habe jetzt dieses t
shirt von lidl die frau kann davon nicht
leben glauben sie dass das ist was der
verbraucher meint wenn er sich so ein t
shirt bezogen sie gekauft bin davon
überzeugt dass die meisten verbrauchern
und verbraucher sich tatsächlich
wünschen würden das zu fairen
bedingungen eben auch eine faire
bezahlung gehört und von daher ist es
jetzt unser wie ich finde ambitioniertes
ziel innerhalb der nächsten zwei jahre
wirklich eine strategie vorzulegen wie
wir im rahmen des grünen knopfes mehr
dazu tun können das ist wirklich
existenzsichernde löhne gibt und man
könnte nicht jetzt als regierungsseite
sagen nein schluss damit also diese
produktionsbedingungen in bangladesch
indonesien wo auch immer das geht mit
uns nicht aber sich etwas grundlegendes
ändern aber sehen sie es gibt einen
freien welthandel und wir als
bundesrepublik deutschland profitieren
in hohem maße davon da können wir nicht
einfach sagen als bundesrepublik
deutschland wir machen jetzt mal unsere
grenzen dicht für bestimmte produkte
doch wie kann sich etwas verändern
ich habe jedenfalls die lust mehr neue
hemden zu kaufen gründlich verloren und
lasse meine alten lieber noch einmal
beim schneider ausbessern
ich kann kleine schritte gehen um die
menschen in den produktionsländern zu
unterstützen mir zum beispiel meinen
konsum bewusster machen
große schritte muss die politik gehen
und im welthandel vernünftige standard
durchsetzen was wir brauchen sind textil
siegel die wirklich etwas verändern
siegel die dafür sorgen dass mensch und
natur nicht ausgebeutet werden
[Musik]